nous avons voté au Sénat une proposition
de loi visant à instaurer une majorité
numérique et lutter contre la haine en
ligne parce qu'on est parti d'abord d'un
certain constat d'abord près de la
moitié des 6-10 ans aujourd'hui sont
titulaires d'un smartphone plus de la
moitié des 10-14 ans se sont inscrits
sur un réseau social et puis plus de la
moitié des adolescents ont confié dans
des enquêtes qu'il serait dévastées
s'ils devaient se déconnecter des
réseaux sociaux alors non pas à vie mais
l'histoire de quelques jours ça en dit
long sur le côté addictif justement des
réseaux sociaux donc on a souhaité
justement au Sénat et au sein de notre
groupe les républicains d'investir le
sujet pour faire de la prévention et
surtout de placer l'autorité parentale
au cœur du dispositif il ne s'agit pas
d'une loi qui va sanctionner les
utilisateurs des réseaux sociaux mais
tout simplement replacer l'autorité
parentale responsabiliser aussi les
parents et l'enfant l'objectif de cette
loi c'est que à partir de 15 ans un
adolescent pourra être titulaire d'un
réseau social en dessous de 15 ans il
aura besoin d'autorisation d'un de ces
deux parents
toute la littérature scientifique et les
enquêtes qui sont menées sur la
sur-utilisation des écrans et des
réseaux sociaux par les plus jeunes
justement ont démontré convergent en
tout cas vers le même constat celui des
conséquences néfastes qu'elles soient
psychiques sociales psychologique donc
on a souhaité placer la famille au
centre de ce dispositif décisionnaire
donc c'est pas un texte qui vise à
sanctionner mais plutôt à
responsabiliser j'ai envie de dire aussi
à sensibiliser donc les parents mais
également les enfants justement à cette
surutilisation le Sénat a proposé des
amendements et à réussi à faire voter
dans la loi finale un certain nombre
d'apports et d'avancés qui visent
justement aussi à responsabiliser les
plateformes elles-mêmes c'est-à-dire les
réseaux sociaux afin qu'ils puissent par
exemple notifier à l'utilisateur le
temps d'écran pour justement un peu nous
rappeler un peu comme un garde-fou du
temps qu'on peut perdre finalement sur
les réseaux sociaux donc c'est un texte
qui était attendu c'est un texte qui est
devenu un outil pour les familles plus
de 80% des adolescents qui sont sur sur
Internet consultent sans consulter leurs
parents justement les parents ne
consulte pas ce que font les enfants sur
Internet alors je peux comprendre que
quand on a un smartphone en tant
qu'enfant ou en tant que parents on
n'est pas toujours l'un à côté de
l'autre mais ça en dit long justement
sur tout le champ exploratoire que
peuvent avoir les adolescents sur les
réseaux sociaux donc le fait de faire
voter cette loi sur la majorité
numérique elle est là pour sensibiliser
les familles les sensibilisations les
sensibiliser à cette surexposition et au
risque néfastes véritablement que l'on
peut constater j'ai eu l'occasion
d'auditionner des professionnels de la
santé tous convergent vers l'idée
justement qu'il faut absolument mettre
en place des garde-four responsabilisés
sur les dangers donc voilà c'était
l'objectif de cette proposition de loi
on se rend compte aujourd'hui que la
plupart des pilleurs ceux qui cassent ce
qui agresse justement durant ces émeutes
ce sont des mineurs avec énormément de
jeunes de moins de 17 ans je crois
qu'aujourd'hui il y a un problème
d'éducation et d'assimilation je crois
qu'un enfant de 12 ans n'a rien à faire
dans la rue à 2h du matin en train de
piller un commerce ou un établissement
public et les réseaux sociaux ne doivent
pas être complices de ces violences
urbaines au contraire elles doivent
responsabilités à elle justement de
diffuser à l'inverse des messages
justement aux utilisateurs des réseaux
sociaux pour leur demander de ne pas
diffuser ce genre de contenu et au
contraire de faire l'inverse donc les
réseaux sociaux ont un rôle majeur ils
doivent pas amplifier les violences
urbaines et justement attiser cette
haine entre français mais bien au
contraire s'en servir justement pour
essayer de rétablir l'ordre dans la
mesure du possible je crois que ça c'est
important et puis il faut savoir que
enregistrer sciemment un contenu que ce
soit une image ou une vidéo sur des
infractions c'est interdit et je crois
qu'aujourd'hui il faut véritablement
faire appliquer cette loi et
sensibiliser les plateformes les réseaux
sociaux attention à ne pas être les
complices de ces violences urbaines